the Senate tax bill is also stuffed with
provisions for special interests car
dealerships would be able to fully
deduct interest on loans
thanks to Kentucky Senator Rand Paul an
amendment by Texas senator Ted Cruz
allows parents to pay for K through 12
private school tuition using tax-free
college savings accounts and senator rob
portman of ohio where big private jet
companies are based reportedly got them
exempted from a levy known as a ticket
tax Julianna Goldman is outside the
capital with other items buried in the
legislation Julianna good morning good
morning well some of the biggest winners
in this bill are passed through
businesses now these are businesses that
pass the income through to their owners
who don't pick corporate taxes instead
they file that income on their
individual tax returns the Senate's tax
bill is a boon for oil and gas firms who
would be able to take advantage of the
lower tax rates on pass-through
businesses the provision was added by
Texas Senator John Cornyn whose campaign
has received more than a million dollars
in contributions from the oil and gas
industry since 2013 we're gonna find
some really stinky stuff in here that we
didn't know on Face the Nation Maine's
independent senator angus King said
there's a lot he and his colleagues
still need to learn real estate
developers like President Trump in the
Trump Organization would also benefit
from the tax cuts for pass-through
businesses according to former Obama tax
policy advisor Seth Hamlin he is sort of
the poster child here of the type of
wealthy businessperson or wealthy
billionaire who's going to get a massive
windfall from this tax cut the
President's budget director Mick
Mulvaney defended the measures yeah
you're gonna change the way we treat
again pass-through entities but a lot of
the deductions are gone up the bill
would also open up part of the Arctic
National Wildlife Refuge to drilling a
cause championed by Alaska senator Lisa
Murkowski she was one of the last GOP
holdouts on the tax plan this is good
for Alaska but more importantly it's
good for the country another amendment
spared cruise lines from paying higher
taxes Alaska Senator Dan Sullivan said
it would help communities and businesses
that rely on tourism this is just a slap
- sloppy untransparent
lawmaking and I frankly have never seen
anything like this the bill is also
notable for what it doesn't include it
appears that a research and development
tax credit was accidentally eliminated
and Norah you can expect more surprises
as lawmakers finish reading the bill
that they've already passed
Wow Julianna thank you